[Musik]
man versucht vertraut zu werden mit dem
flugzeug das flugzeug genau kennen zu
lernen
man versucht so sucht nicht nur man
möchte die entsprechenden figuren
fliegen können es macht auch spaß die
beschleunigung spüren diese dynamik die
drin ist die situation des motors das
ganze drumherum
das gibt einen anteil ja schon ein kick
wenn man den trend setzt
stefan grillenberg lebt seinen traum der
passionierte kunstflieger und fluglehrer
verbringt am boden nur so viel zeit wie
unbedingt nötig viel ist das nicht denn
der 48 jährige ingenieur ist testpilot
des deutschen zentrums für luft und
raumfahrt und geht auch beruflich
ständig in die luft in meiner größe
grünweg noch mal ich hätte gerne das
aktuelle wetter von ruby von 920 der
wind 0 10 grad für das knoten in
schwankt zwischen 3 40 grad und 60 grad
die 69 kilometer die zwischen news
hinter karl maier
danke herr der flugplatz
oberpfaffenhofen liegt 25 kilometer
westlich von münchen heimat der
forschungs flieger
das deutsche zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt beschäftigt hier 1500
mitarbeiter weltraum mission
klimaforschung erdbeobachtung
oberpfaffenhofen zählt neben dem
standort köln zu den größten
forschungszentren deutschlands das ist
der arbeitsplatz von stefan grillen beck
gulfstream g 550 eigentlich ein
business-jet kosten 40 millionen euro
ohne extras diese sonderanfertigung
heißt hallo und war um einiges teurer
hallo das bedeutet hrt stewart and long
range research aircraft ein langstrecken
forschungsflugzeug mit einer reichweite
von 8000 kilometern
für die klima- und umweltforschung sind
solche flugzeuge unverzichtbar
forschungs flugzeuge schließen wunderbar
eine lücke zwischen bodenstationen und
satelliten satelliten können eben nur zu
bestimmten zeiten an bestimmten orten
messen bodenstationen selbstverständlich
auch nur an einem bestimmten ort und mit
forschungs flugzeugen können sie
dreidimensional beliebige lufträume
perfekt vermessen mit 17 war stefan
koubek begeisterter segelflieger aus dem
segelflug wurde schnell ein motorsegler
wenig später ein propellerflugzeug 1994
entschloss sich der flug
versuchsingenieur verkehrs pilot zu
werden und um seine ausbildung zu
finanzieren musste er neben jobs
annehmen
so arbeitete er unter anderem bei der
post und pakete aus ich konnte mir das
damals als ich angefangen habe mit dem
segelfliegen 17 18 nicht vorstellen dass
ich hier sitze oder diese kampagnen
fliege oder dieses neue
forschungsflugzeug fliegen darf
die welt zu sehen das war schon immer
ein traum von mir das so das
faszinierende welt haben und wir erleben
sie wirklich auch in extremen regionen
wir sehen sagen die andere leute nicht
sehen können und das ist schon eine
bereichung bereits 2005 verließ die gt5
den hangar in savannah usa drei jahre
lang wurde der businessjet vorgerüstet
der umbau erfolgt in oberpfaffenhofen
verstärkte tragflächen und eine
spezielle stromversorgung die den
einsatz wissenschaftlicher geräte
innerhalb und außerhalb der kabine
erlaubt bis zu drei tonnen an
instrumenten und material nimmt der jet
mit auf seiner reise über
ozeane und an die polkappen
[Applaus]
15 kilometer hoch kann halo fliegen so
wie einst nur die concorde zahlreiche
missionen sind bereits in planung es
geht um wolkenbildung die
klimaveränderung oder extreme
wetterereignisse wie gewitter in
gewittern zum beispiel entstehen eben in
den blitz kanälen stickoxide und diese
entstehen aber auch hauptsächlich durch
den menschen eben durch verkehr durch
verbrennung fossiler brennstoffe und da
möchte man natürlich auch wissen wo
liegen da die unterschiede was ist
natürlich entstanden wir vieles
natürlich entstanden und was wird
sozusagen vom menschen gemacht da haben
wir auch flüge in gewitterzonen gemacht
das wetter überall auf der welt
beschäftigen sich menschen ob hobby
piloten oder wissenschaftler mit
extremem wetter und seinen gefahren für
flugzeuge erkenntnisse aus derartigen
flügen sind für die fliegerei enorm
wichtig auch wenn solche manöver einiges
an mut verlangen kein pilot einer
passagiermaschine würde freiwillig in
ein gewitter einfliegen
doch manchmal sind sie plötzlich da
mensch und maschine mitten drin
[Musik]
so wie am ersten juni 2009 beim absturz
des air france fluges 447 sterben 228
menschen auf dem weg von rio de janeiro
nach paris gerät der airbus a330 in ein
heftiges gewitter
wenig später stürzt das flugzeug in den
atlantik fragen nach der ursache bleiben
auch wochen danach defekte
geschwindigkeitsmesser werden genannt
und eine unglückliche verkettung der
folgenden ereignisse abseits der
technisch relevanten ursachen bleibt bei
außenstehenden eine frage unbeantwortet
kann ein gewitter können widrige
wetterumstände überhaupt die alleinige
ursache für einen flugzeugabsturz seien
rückblick das erste düsen
verkehrsflugzeug der welt die comet
hergestellt wurde der vierstrahlige
tiefdecker vom britischen flugzeugbauer
die herr wieland
was zunächst als durchbruch in der
luftfahrt geschichte gefeiert wurde
endete in einer serie von tragischen
unfällen
mitte der 50er jahre zerbrachen vier
maschinen während des fluges im abstand
von nur wenigen monaten zunächst wurde
schlechtes wetter als ursache vermutet
später stellte sich heraus es war ein
konstruktionsfehler türen und fenster
der komet hielten einer geschwindigkeit
nahe der schallgrenze schlicht nicht
stand und das obwohl auch schon damals
umfangreiche belastungstests an der
tagesordnung war
zwischenfälle wie bei der comet versucht
die forschung am flugzeug seit jeher zu
verhindern
zu beginn der luftfahrt war das reine
pionierarbeit ein völlig neues feld
vorkenntnisse und erfahrungswerte gab es
nicht bei der eroberung des himmels fing
man bei null an
erkenntnisse über die festigkeit von
material über das was ein flugzeug
aushalten kann welchen kräften ist
ausgesetzt ist weil das gewannen
experten oft erst nach verheerenden
katastrophe
heute unterhalten institute wie das
deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
eine ganze flotte von forschungs
flugzeugen und hubschraubern
oberstes ziel der forschung am und mit
dem flugzeug weniger schadstoffe
klimaschutz und weniger unfälle
wir haben ja zwei flug abteilungen im
dlr in oberpfaffenhofen machen wir
forschung mit dem flugzeug neben auf dem
gebiet atmosphärenforschung ehrt
erkundung geo science in braunschweig
wird die forschung am flugzeug in den
vordergrund gestellt hier werden zum
beispiel daneben optimale
anflugverfahren für piloten getestet
dass sie auch bei schlechtem wetter sich
im gelände auskennen
dort haben wir die großen fliegenden
simulatoren mit denen wir auch das
flugverhalten antrag zum teil noch gar
nicht gebaut
flugzeuge und hubschrauber nachbilden
können und somit deren entwicklung
beeinflussen können und sehr viele teure
experimente oder fehlplanung verhindern
können sie sind im hangar der
flugsportgruppe oberpfaffenhofen
es ist so etwas wie die zweite heimat
von stefan grillen beck ein letzter
check vor dem start die
lebensversicherung eines jeden piloten
der eigene hinter der da drin sitzt und
wir checken jetzt aber alle wieder frei
gängig sind auch keine beschädigung dran
sind
ob sie nicht irgendwas gelöst hat vorher
ob der motor in ordnung ist stand passt
alles was so wichtig ist zum fliegen
was müssen wir hier gucken an der fläche
zum beispiel wir schauen einfach die
landeklappen in ordnung sehen ob sich
hier nichts gelöst hat dann auf die
verkleidung in alle fest sind keine
schrauben gelöst haben schon mit dem
reifendruck an
auch kein spiel der beleuchtung für die
vorderkante dann kann man für die
partner zwei anzeigen
die auspuffanlage festes
diese verkleidung
und keine undichtigkeiten da sind das
ganze macht weimar
und vorne wieder draußen stand war dann
vom hier rein das ist nicht irgendein
fremdkörper sich da angesammelt hat also
das zeigt auch so ein bisschen fliegen
es vor allen dingen auch gute
vorberatungen ja meist nicht so wie beim
autofahren meistens hätten sie haben wir
einfach rein und fahren im auto los
obwohl man in der fahrschule ja mal
gelernt hat man soll mal ausland umgehen
mal schauen ob alle reifendruck haben ob
eine beleuchtung funktioniert blinker
funktionieren da der unterschied dürfte
dann auch sein dass man nicht auf den
parkstreifen fahren kann wenn das ist ja
man kann nicht anhaltenden luft man muss
dann mit dem zurechtkommen was man
vorher vergessen hat
hier ist noch muskelkraft gefragt und
wenn es gleich wieder in die luft geht
steht sicherheitstraining auf dem
programm
beim kunstflug wird stefan grillen beck
seinen vereinskollegen zeigen wie man
mit gefährlichen flug zuständen umgeht
wie man richtig reagiert was wenn die
strömung abreißt oder der motor ausfällt
sicherheit auch für privatpiloten ein
großes anliegen von stefan grillen
[Musik]
aufgebockt steht die halo in eigens
gebauten hangar bevor die dlr
testpiloten die ersten runden drehen
können muss der flieger vom luftfahrt
bundesamt zugelassen werden
das ist etwa so wie beim tüv nur ein
wenig aufwendiger ein expertenteam vom
institut für aero lästig in göttingen
nimmt die maschine genau unter die lupe
wie verändert sich das flugverhalten des
jets wenn er durch turbulenzen oder ein
manöver des piloten starken schwingungen
ausgesetzt ist
wozu eigentlich diese tests die sich
jetzt durch also mit diesen tests
möchten wir natürlich gewährleisten dass
ein sicherer betrieb dieser dieses
flugzeug möglich ist sie sehen hier
diese anbauteile die wir an den
tragflächen montiert haben und wir
möchten mit unseren versuchen eben
sicherstellen dass wir dieses flugzeug
wenn wir das in betrieb nehmen und mit
dem gewissen höhen weil gewissen
geschwindigkeiten fliegen dass dort
keine gefährlichen schwingungs phänomene
auftreten bei diesem würden eine
gefährdung nicht nur der der insassen
des flugzeugs bedeuten sondern auch alle
diejenigen personen die unter der flut
unter dem flugzeug im prinzip das heißt
es geht um die gewährleistung der
sicheren betriebes des flugzeugs jetzt
wenn man das so sieht hier die
tragfläche das klingt ja schon ganz
deutlich unter 4 angst bekommen wenn man
zukünftig dem flugzeug steigt nein das
müssen sie natürlich nicht
also dieses flugzeug ist ja von der
bauart her eine eine gulfstream g 550
das ist eigentlich ein business-jet den
sie so auch kaufen kommen können von dem
hersteller geist rihm und als
eigentlicher business jet hat dieses
flugzeug eine zulassung und kann auch
sicher betrieben werden
das hat der hersteller natürlich
nachgewiesen was wir jetzt vom dlr
machen wir bauen dieses flugzeug um in
ein forschungsflugzeug indem wir dort
eben anbauteile unter die tragfläche
montieren können die dann auch für
atmosphärenforschung genutzt werden
können
diese anbauten bedeuten eine
modifikation des flugzeugs die einen
starken eingriff in die aerodynamik
bedeutet und dadurch sagt eben der
flugzeughersteller
wir können den sicheren betrieb das
flugzeug mit diesen anbauteilen nicht
mehr gewährleisten und es ist eine
ergänzung bei der zulassung des
flugzeugs erforderlich und das möchten
wir mit unseren versuchen hier
erreichten
das heißt ja mit gerade davon geschockt
das heißt ja sie müssen mit
verschiedenen anbauten diese tests
durchführen was sehen wir jetzt zb hier
jetzt war das ist ein anbau das ist ein
so genannter pms carrier das ist ein
anbau der hier wissenschaftliche
instrumente tragen soll
diese dienen der atmosphärenforschung wo
man in großer höhe eben auch die
zusammensetzung der luft messen möchte
und damit ein sicherer betrieb da mit
diesem anbauteil möglich ist machen wir
diesen versuch hier wo wir das anbauteil
an das flugzeug montieren und wir messen
die schwingungs eigenschaften des
flugzeugs am boden um mit diesen
gemessenen schwingungs eigenschaften
hinterher eine sogenannte flattr analyse
durchführen zu können
das bedeutet wir simulieren mit den
gemessenen daten am boden
wie wird sich das flugzeug verhalten
wenn wir es in betrieb nehmen wenn wir
in großer höhe mit großer
geschwindigkeit fliegen
wie wird das schwingungsverhalten sein
wenn das flugzeug in der luft ist im
betrieb und wir möchten eben prüfen und
vermeiden dass es gefährliche
schwingungs situation im betrieb geben
kann
damit er gültig punkt zwei uhr auftritt
der piloten stefan grillen beck und
roland welser wann briefing der halo
mannschaft in anderthalb stunden soll es
losgehen
herzlich willkommen bei uns hier im
neuen hamburg hallo hunger wir freuen
uns dass mit einem flug können zusammen
sind fernsehsender für die
sicherheitsleute an bord wird der herr
wolf und der enns zuständig sein wir
machen nachher noch an bord eine
einweisung dann wird sie über alles
bescheid wissen und soll den fluges
auftreten dann auch an die beiden
kernsegmenten es wird aber auch in so
mancher vom cockpit kommen wir in ein
notlager gekommen wir haben das
natürlich abarbeiten und dann wieder
wenn es möglich ist in oberpfaffenhofen
landen sollte man einen bremsenproblemen
haben oder ein größeres problem dann
wird man den menschen gehen auf die
längere bahn gut der flug wird alles
nach sichtflugregeln durchgeführt wir
erwarten dass wir heute auch die viel
verkehr von kleinflugzeugen in der luft
haben das heißt wir müssen auch gute
luftraum beobachtung durchführen da hast
du am kopf betrat beschäftigt damit wir
bitten auch sie wenn irgendwas auftreten
sollte im flutlicht 7 flugzeug sehen
können sie uns das auch gerne melden
damit man da gewarnt sind
wir werden also überwachen rufen in
richtung der wind hat gedreht richtung
04 verlassen dann der rechts platz kurve
machen über den ammersee richtung kennt
den fliegen dann die ganzen kempten
entlang der alpen jemand fragen sie die
hintenrum kapo zug schließlich ist da
entstanden richtung chiemsee fliegen und
vom kind dann aber wieder zurück fliegen
richtung starnberg sti und dann im
anflug machen auf die wahrscheinlich auf
die 0 4 in oberpfaffenhofen
[Musik]
es ist ein aufbruch ins ungewisse die
test fliegerei eine der letzten
herausforderungen für berufs pilot die
maschine an die grenzen von material und
aerodynamik fliegen manchmal auch
darüber hinaus als testpilot wird man
flugzeuge teilweise über den
zugelassenen flugbereich hinaus
betreiben um bestimmte nachweise zu
erbringen für außenanlagen zum beispiel
um sicherzugehen dass im normalen
betrieb nichts passiert deswegen muss
man teilweise darüber hinausgehen über
diesem zugelassenen flugbereich
[Musik]
was wir teilweise machen oder gemacht
haben in vergangenheit wir sind hinter
verkehrsflugzeuge nicht mehr geflogen
haben schadstoffe gemessen
wir sind tief im ärmelkanal geflogen
haben abgase von schiffen gemessen das
sind der flug szenarien die in normaler
pilot in seinem leben nicht fliegen wird
wir sind auf dem weg zum flugzeugbauer
airbus in toulouse
die reise beginnt im bayerischen
manching militärisches sicherheits
gelände
streng abgeschirmt keine kameras dieser
airbus a 320 war einmal ein
urlaubsflieger heute sitzen hier keine
touristen sondern wissenschaftler die
kabine voll gestopft mit
hochleistungsrechnern und messgeräten im
gegensatz zum viel kleineren hj et wird
mit dieser maschine forschung am
flugzeug betrieben nicht klima oder
erdbeobachtung steht im vordergrund
stattdessen effiziente triebwerke
lärmschutz flugsicherheit auf den
rechnern in der kabine sehen die
ingenieure fast alles was auf die
piloten sehen mit hilfe der so genannten
cockpit schnittstelle können sie
neuartige formen der flugsteuerung
erproben ja sogar das autonome fliegen
spielt hier eine rolle
dlr pilot andreas hahn und kapitän karl
heinz may von airbus testpiloten der
klasse 1 diese beiden wissen als erstes
ob ein neues flugzeug fliegt oder nicht
heute allerdings alles entspannt der
airbus a320 hat schon etliche
flugstunden auf dem buckel
ein airbus ingenieur begleitet die
mission nach toulouse
ein wichtiges thema auf diesem flug die
aero elastisch wie reagiert ein flugzeug
auf schwingungen ist es wichtig nicht
dass das problem beim flugzeug ist es
bewegt sich in einem medium dass das
wirklich um sprung da gibt es
interaktionen zwischen wurf zwischen
umstellung der aerodynamik und des
flugzeugs und das nero lustig und
diagnostik eines flugzeugs muss so
ausgelegt sein dass eine maximale
geschwindigkeit nicht dazu führt dass
der flügel in schwingungen gerät und
dabei abbrechen kann aber ganz sicher
auch noch mal auf den aspekt sicher
zurück zu kommen
ein flugzeug ist immer so ausgelegt dass
es zu diesen punkten einen maximalen
sicherheitsabstand hat dass ein flugzeug
im normalen betrieb nie in solchen
situationen kommen kann dass ein solcher
fall eintrete und auch genau aus diesem
grunde werden halt solche untersuchung
im vorfeld als erstes bei straße gemacht
nach anderthalb stunden die landung in
toulouse
friedrich ritter ritter
das airbus werk liegt gleich am
flughafen diese nagelneuen maschinen
warten schon auf ihre besitzer
flugzeugbauer wie airbus setzen ganz
konkrete hoffnungen in die
forschungsarbeiten des dlr
schon bald sollen experimente die jetzt
noch in der luft stattfinden am boden
möglich sein
das spart nicht nur enorme kosten
sondern auch aufwendige forschungsreihe
so können beim bau eines prototypen
mehrere millionen euro eingespart werden
die verfahren für schwingungs tests am
boden sind gerade entwickelt worden die
patente werden vom dlr bereits angeboten
zurück in oberpfaffenhofen eine kleine
hinterhof garage hier erdet sich der
testpilot eine russische uran mit
beiwagen hilft ihm dabei das schrauben
liegt dem buch aus dem fränkischen wohl
im blut der vater war werkzeugmacher
hatte eine eigene kleine werk als
grünberg mit dem segelfliegen anfängt
ist es vor allem die schrauberei am
flieger die ihn fasziniert wer sich
beruflich fliegen wenn sie nicht privat
fliegen dann wird geschraubt und wie
viel zeit verbringen sie dabei also wozu
wird geschraubt
das wichtigste schon mit familie aber
ich denke mal eine woche im schnitt
vielleicht stunden mal was macht im
winter mehr dass man also sagen wieder
herrichten kann dass man auf dem land
verbessern kann seine wünsche ausleben
das fahrzeug war sie so bauen wie man
möchte ist dass der ingenieur in ihrem
herzen ja klar das war schon in der
jugend so mein vater muss nicht mal
assistieren in der werkstatt und man
sich dann 14 15 gegen das los mit mopeds
auch im boot passieren was man immer so
macht was man nicht darf aber dadurch
lernt man natürlich die technik kennen
von seinem motorrad und zeit lang konnte
ist dann nicht mehr leisten wenn im
studium dagegen halt nur ein auto und
jetzt nach dem studium habe ich dann
wieder angefangen zu sammeln und kauft
ab und zu sogar alte motorräder auch
noch richtig wieder her
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stefan grünbeck in seinem element ob als
forschungs flieger an der arktis hoch
über dem ozean oder im alpenvorland er
liebt ganz einfach seinen beruf und wenn
man es ganz genau nimmt haben wir am
ende alle etwas davon
[Musik]